[Applause]
[Music]
the damage is not too bad as long as the
foundations are still strong we can
rebuild this place it will become a
haven for all peoples and aliens of the
universe now those foundations are gone
sorry how did you get here my brain now
we don't know where all Tron's headed
but you're going very high very fast so
I need you to turn this bird around okay
we can't track you in stealth mode so I
need you to help me out okay
[Applause]
[Music]
stay I'm down running short on options
[Applause]
[Music]
happy holidays from the Avengers
everyone they're dropping all kinds of
stuff because it's the end of the year
just watching the Hulk pound the
Lightning right out of Thor
if you didn't know - I'm doing an
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway I'll do that
in all my Marvel videos but all you have
to do to enter that it'd just be a
subscriber and leave a Marvel related
comment on the video this is mostly
straight up I've gotten a ton of
questions about what happened to serger
at the end of that what happened to
hella and where they're gonna pick up
with infinity war what I'll probably end
up happening is this hella is chilling
in a script on a shelf somewhere till
phase four maybe Avengers for inclusion
because that's mostly Infinity Gauntlet
resolution Danis assembling the gauntlet
full-on and we don't know how they've
worked death into that equation if it's
an actual character like the cosmic
entity death or if it's gonna be the
hell of character there's just a lot of
speculation we haven't heard any
confirmation about Kate Blanchet being
back on set for Avengers 4 and they've
actually been posting a lot of stuff and
even if that Thor post-credit scene
isn't going to be the first scene of
infinity war it's got to be one of the
second ones because Hulk has to make it
all the way back to earth probably with
the help of the tesseract
thank you very much Loki so that he can
warn everyone that Thanos is coming
while he's already trounced the Nova
Corps to take the power gem and the
space gem and it sounds like based on
Kevin Feige his comments at a recent
convention that Loki will pretend to be
working with nanos so it sounds like he
hands him the tesseract without him
having to take it from him so when you
see him in the trailer walking over all
these dead bodies this could be on earth
inside the sanctum sanctorum or it could
be somewhere else because that sounds
like it's the way that Hulk gets back to
Planet Earth but let me know in the
comments what's your favorite part of
this door behind the scenes what was
your favorite big action scene from that
movie because it was essentially a
string of big action set pieces with a
lot of jokes strung in with a lot of
humor about the previous Thor films and
the other Marvel movies Suns getting
real low big guy so they'll probably be
some more stuff posting before the end
of the year but leave all your bonus
video requests in the comments below
I'll keep doing that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway until we get to infinity war so
no worries but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner from my last
video Isaiah Adams please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll just name a new winner
I post new marble but happy holidays
click here to learn more about the venom
movie in carnage and click here for
brand new infinity war thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]